[Applaudissements]
et on va commencer ce quart d'heure sans
fil par un homme premières infos elle
est complètement ouf le petit joshua
trump a quitté son école aux états unis
et a failli changer de nom de famille
tellement il se faisait harceler à
l'école le pauvre garçon et où il
faisait partie de la grande famille des
nom difficile à porter dans un instant
aura deux jeunes filles qui ont des noms
très difficile à porter vous allez
essayer de trouver de quoi il s'agit on
vous résume tout ça en images on en
parle juste après c'est parti
à l'école on le sait les enfants ne sont
pas toujours tendre quand il s'agit de
chambrée ou de stigmatiser leurs
camarades
il faut dire que quand on porte le nom
d'un des présidents les plus
controversés du moment pas facile de se
faire respecter
c'est la mésaventure qui est arrivée à
joshua trump à un jeune garçon de 11 ans
qui ne fait pas partie de la famille du
président américain mais qui porte
simplement le même nom que lui un hasard
qui va lui causer bien des soucis
pendant plusieurs mois le jeune garçon
va être harcelées et moqué à l'école à
cause de son nom à tel point que ses
parents vont le déscolarisés pour qu'ils
suivent des cours à domicile
mais au moment d'intégrer le collège
l'année suivante le cauchemar recommence
et des personnes au nom compliqué on en
trouve beaucoup dans l'annuaire certains
d'entre eux portent le nom de
personnalités controversées comme marine
le pen ou eric zemmour d'autres ont des
noms qui peuvent plus tôt prêter à rire
comme rami rectal myriam gros cul en
riches habitent ou encore madame boudin
qui est en plateau avec nous ce soir
alors heureusement on avait dit qu'on
allait chercher les noms mais j'ai dit
madame boutin alors qu'ils madame du
mois alors on joue soir alors que vous
appelez donc vous êtes vous êtes c'est
qu'on votre nom votre prénom perrine
perrine boudin c'est ça alors perrine ça
doit être une galère à l'école non c'est
mieux que tl a été oui c'est vrai ouais
depuis le cp en cp surtout j'écrivais le
nom de jeune fille de ma mère pour pas
que west va appeler à l'appel du genre
dans la cour et le boudin voilà ça vaut
bout d'un mois les gros relous et voilà
ouais bah ouais bosh était là et
aujourd'hui ça va mieux ma part pas quel
âge
aujourd'hui j'ai 21 ans ça va tu t'en
fou oui ça va maintenant j'en ris moi
même j'ai envie de te marier très vite
pour chacun gérait pas jusque là mais
voilà au moins j'en rigole moi même
comme ça on peut pas se moquer de moi
nkon alors vous vous avez un nom un peu
plus facile à porter mais quand même
c'est sur un autre trio nice a cédé 6 et
la perte série alors on va en parler
pour l'instant parce que nous on a vu de
l'histoire du petit joshua trump et il
est devenu mondialement connu les
ménages niamey l'ania trump on a faim
c'est un symbole contre le harcèlement à
l'école
il a même été invité mardi soir assister
dans l'enceinte du congrès américain à
l'un des plus prestigieux moments de la
vie politique américaine
sauf que ce moment qu'ils étaient censés
être très solennelle joshua sang balech
total regardent ils s'appellent trump
mais il n'a pas de lien de parenté avec
le président américain mais un lien
quand même alors il est bienvenu au
discours sauf que ça s'est pas vraiment
passé
comment on l'attendait parce qu'il a été
littéralement assommé par le discours du
président alors l'image oaci notamment
mais daniel est concentrée elle avait
plané beaucoup plus souriant il s'est
endormi alors on va voir d'autres non
voilà qui sont pas faciles à porter
regardez par exemple il y avait une
madame qui s'appelait marlène regarder
son nom de famille c'était un moment
regardez c'est regarder comment vous
appelez-vous je m'appelle clarisse
bonnichon claret
mais c'est dommage que vous appeliez pas
par votre deuxième prénom puisque c'est
aimer aimer boni chance est d'avoir un
mec 63 c'est le sait le tour où c'est le
sait la taille c'est beau quand vous
décrivez votre identité
quelle est la réaction des gens sont
plutôt gêné en fait nous on vit très
bien d'ailleurs tous mais c'est plutôt
nos interlocuteurs qui se sentent un peu
gêné marlène donc vous vous appelez
marley une [ __ ]
vous avez 19 ans vous êtes lycée elle
est ce que vous essayez de tricher avec
votre nom oui en fait je dis quand je
commente aux gens jeudi marine saloper
saloper lui alors comment ça se passe au
lycée musiciens c'est la rentrée c'est
l'angoissé quoi parce que c'est l'appel
et puis les led sont écrit en majuscules
donc y'a même pas moyen de tricher et
dans la rue vous entendez aussi quand
les gens connaissent votre nom d'aidés
des choses particulières wiba dans mon
lycée régulièrement comme bas dans les
couloirs j'entends crier ça loeb dans
tous les coins
une fatigue sébastien donc vous appeler
sébastien connard vous avez 23 ans vous
êtes éducateurs sportifs quels sont les
blacks que vous entendez plus facile sur
vous ce surtout quand j'étais petit
l'école primaire ou au collège tricolore
j'étais content c'était populaire dans
le collège
c'est comme moi les gens améliora tienne
mon nom ils savent qui suit alors que
perrine boudin ce que vous avez déjà
pensé à changer de nom en vrai j'y ai
pensé mais en cp donc ça date
ouais mon oncle l'a fait pour mes petits
cousins et ses terrasses qui était au
grand sacrilège de mon père ah ouais
mais moi docteur vous aviez on est des
boudins on ne restera tout on est fiers
d'être des boudins c'est ça alors on en
à côté laura alors vous l'aura vous avez
18 ans c'est en première année de dut en
génie biologique
quand même nez de franconville dans le
95 et vous à votre avis comment comment
elle s'appelle allez vous avez ces
politiques pour trouver une issue
politique à quoi ces politiques
non c'est une astuce de l'hygiène c'est
quoi une insulte non c'est pas une
ancienne gardienne non la nourriture non
c'est un nom de famille qui existe déjà
chez un homme politique ou une célébrité
en redemander non non non non non de
légumes non de genre ah non non une
partie corporelle non non un pays non
ben quoi c'est pas très grave s'appelle
c'est un site non c'est pas une insulte
une partie du corps non ça manimal quoi
un animal non on a déjà demandé si
sexuelle à les y aider sans avoir aucune
profession nicotine lutte là s'appelle
laura connard put lors à la voile alors
alors dans la ville aura la [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez nous en belgique on ad van de putte
maintenant je sais pas si c'est ça non
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça laura tapant
[Rires]
tudela la pop
laura a voulu donner à notre année cent
par rapport à ce qu'on a viré dans la
vidéo de c'est mon choix
d'accord alors alors allez allez c'est
le rab en plus pas loin non c'est pas ça
c'est pas beaucoup mais c'est lourd à
jean cocteau rageant mais non les débats
mais la nuit laura baleines y aura beau
ça non non laura gynéco laura fillon
[Applaudissements]
professionnalise au chômage en mars et
on leur laisse coi et l'autre on l'a
jamais vu ça j'ai raté son oui j'adore
les jeux à palois l'europe et à l'europe
alors à coacher alors à la chaudière la
bombasse palois poursuivre bons
souvenirs
[Rires]
nantes et on le rate et on l'aurait
vidée mais on n'est pas non plus un an
avec les miens ouais alors laura la
smera tort aller comment s'appelle laura
si vous dangereux c'est pas mal aura
fait le tout sympa mais ça va pas
rigoler tous les sens mais les mineurs à
excuser ni alors le ménage et non des
tâches ont allégé aux dires c'est lourd
laura chiffonnette couasnon titre nous
l'aura à quoi une dernière chance
elle aura dans le cul
[Applaudissements]
ces dernières années plus tard on
s'appelle laura la bonne morale à bonn
voilà c'est pas c'est pas hyper sinon je
te plains les micros de deux de leurs
bolides jean-michel souper en régie
laura laura la bonne s'est passé ça va
ça va non mais c'est ça que ça c'est
difficile quand on est en cours mais ce
qui s'est passé hier ça vous aide à
relativiser
non mais c'est vrai que c'est pas hyper
grave parce que laura boudin franchement
évident assure fois mieux c'est en fait
assez simple
fabio sans voix pierre dans son fois
pire enfin moi ah non là ça veut dire
crottes de nez aux tunisiens moi je
m'appelle série crottes de nez c'est
pire que vous
franchement je vous le dis un jean
michel maire
bon là je passe oui mais non mais oui
mais le nom votre nom votre pass mais
papa vous non mais franchement les
filles en tout cas et c'est introduire
pour vous c'est quoi les vannes que vous
a fait le ménage tout ça franchement ça
passe l'aura vu que j'arrivais vous
n'avez jamais pensé changer de nom c'est
oui enfin bon c'est vrai la répétition
de 1,26 à la fin se revoir des
commentaires comme ça ça me tenait à
l'idée de changer de prénom mais bon
j'ai décidé d'assumer aujourd'hui monde
famille ce que je suis voilà alors à la
bonne on alors à la bonne et perrine
boudin en tout cas je vous dis vous êtes
très jolie toutes les deux oui
franchement et vous êtes très
sympathique
changez pas de nom et je vous le dis on
sera des boudins quoi qu'il arrive et on
se battra merci avouant que la merci
[Applaudissements]